can we all just be completely honest
about something for a minute and I'm
putting politics aside just just being
completely honest can we agree at least
that the 1998 impeachment series was way
more entertaining and just better
all-around in the reboot in 2019 I mean
sure you've got the outlandish
characters this time around Trump
obviously Giuliani Joe Biden some good
characters but I'm not sure that they're
really better than the characters in the
original and and I mean but the main
thing is you can only do so much with
characters it all comes down to plot for
me you know as a viewer and the central
plot just isn't nearly as absorbing it's
just in the original show yeah sex lies
you know betrayal it was it was really
it was critics at the time of course
said it veered a little bit too much in
a soap opera territory but but which it
did but this is impeachment we're
talking about that's what the show is
supposed to be like and this time it's
as if the producer said oh no was to
soap opera last time so we're gonna
we're gonna intentionally make this as
dry as possible so it all revolves
around a phone call think about what the
first impeachment series revolved around
think about that and this time we have a
phone call it's just plus I don't want
to bring this up but but someone has to
mention but you know the the the
impeachment 98 had a whole host of
fascinating female characters Lewinsky
Paula Jones even Hillary Clinton with
her Carell advil impression was was was
pretty interested but this time there's
there's basically no female characters
all the female characters have been
replaced by men now all the talk we do
about representation making sure people
are represented is that in 2019 is that
really a choice that can be justified
yeah they brought back Nancy Pelosi and
everything but she just does not she's
the least compelling female character
and she's the only one that carries over
anyway I don't we could just hope that
the show picks up steam in later
episodes and if it doesn't then we also
know that I'm sure they'll reboot it
again in a few years and and I guess we
can hope that that reboot
up to the expectations set by the 98
series and that's all I'm gonna say
about that okay lots to talk about today
including and in fact we're gonna begin
with NBC News calling out myself and Ben
Shapiro and The Daily wire in general
for alleged fake news they say that we
we are responsible for a fake news story
but in the not-so twist ending they are
the ones propagating the fit the fake
news it's gonna shock you to learn that
so we're gonna talk about that in just a
moment but first a word from our friends
at kettle bell kitchen nutrition is the
thing that's on everybody's mind what
when how much to eat it's a mess of
conflicting information that can confuse
anyone it can derail your fitness
journey it's the kind of thing where you
begin I've done this so many times where
I think I want to start eating healthy I
want to get healthy and then I and then
I and then I try to look it up you
google it you just get so confused and
say never mind I'll just stick with
McDonald's there are tons of different
diets and meal plans out there but they
don't really take your own needs into
account and also if I'm being completely
honest I've tried the food from some of
these other meal plans and I just didn't
like it so it came down to that for me
but kettle bell kitchen solves all of
these problems
finally kettle bell kitchen knows that
meal planning isn't one size fits all
what works for your neighbor isn't
necessarily gonna work for you and
that's why they've come up with
personalized solutions kettle bell
kitchen was founded by two Army veterans
were also brothers and a chef with a
mission to help people change their
lives through food their goals to help
you achieve yours with your goals with
with meal plans that are tailored for
your needs and their team of
nutritionists will help create a
sustainable health plan that honors your
body's unique needs also for me I got to
go back to this and emphasize it that
that for me one of the most important
things is the food is good that's what I
want to know you know is the food good
and it is I've tried several several of
their meals I liked it all I especially
liked the the beef the bison beef
sliders I had that a few nights ago
restaurant quality stuff brought right
to your door
take a couple minutes to heat it up and
and you're good to go
can't get any better than that feed the
champion in you with kettle bell kitchen
go to kettle bell kitchen dot-com enter
code Walsh for $50 off your first two
orders for new customers that's $50 off
your first two orders at kettle bell
kitchen dot-com code Walsh all right
last week the daily wire reported that a
drug called Lupron he used as a puberty
blocker for transgender children has
been linked to thousands of deaths now
shortly after this story was published
NBC News and there were other left-wing
outlets and people who also jumped on
this but NBC News in particular
denounced the daily wire for pushing
fake news quote-unquote naming myself
and ben shapiro as the culprits who
shared and disseminated what they called
quote anti-transgender rhetoric
ironically as i said before there their
article debunking our fake news is
itself fake news and i want to talk
about this and get into it
because it touches on how the media
twists things and also when when when
you hear a left-wing outlet like NBC
News talking about fake news well we
start to see what they really mean by
that and also the actual issue here
which isn't what the Daily wire wrote or
anything like that the actual issue is
is these drugs themselves that are being
given to kids so it deals with all that
and that's why I want to talk about this
NBC explains in their in their article
that Lupron is often used to treat
prostate cancer in adult men and and in
most of the deaths associated with the
drug are quote likely among these
patients adult men prostate cancer
that's what the drug is usually used for
now that's that's no doubt probably the
case most of the deaths most of the
adverse reactions to the drugs
are going to
among people with prostate cancer who
are using the drugs to treat that cancer
the daily wired never said otherwise
I never said otherwise in fact in the
original report on the site
it specifically notes that lupron is
being prescribed off-label as a hormone
blocker for gender confused children but
I want you to think about what NBC is
doing here
they are defending the use of this
potentially dangerous drug among
physically healthy children on the basis
that well it's really designed for use
among terminally ill men that's their
defense of the drug they're saying no no
no no no see here this is fake news
really this drug is designed for
terminally ill men with prostate cancer
and that's why we've had these adverse
rection yes exactly
yet this drug that is supposed to be
used in that way or in in in other cases
where people are suffering from actual
real physical problems the drug meant
for that designed for that is being
given to physically healthy children
whose only problem is that they are
confused about their gender and they're
probably only confused about it because
their parents have haven't helped to
clarify the issue in in in most of these
cases even the confusion itself which is
not a physical problem but even the
confusion itself in most these cases are
going to go back to parenting but don't
worry says NBC Lupron is just you know
it's it's it's it's just chemically
castrating those children that's all
most of the people who die from it are
adults
sure we don't really know the the risks
inherent in suppressing the normal
growth and development of children who
are confused about their gender we don't
we don't really know all the risks we
don't really know what it's doing to
them long term we have no we have no
real sample size at all okay you're not
gonna find a lot of adults who are in
their 50s now and have been on this
stuff for 40 years or who use this
you know or who or who used this 40
years ago so we don't really exactly
know but NBC says I don't you know it
don't worry it's probably not killing
them it's probably the people that are
dying from it probably the adults and in
as far as we know anyway and so we don't
have to worry about it but forget about
the adverse side effects for a minute
all right the desired effect the desired
effect of a drug like lupron in a
healthy child is adverse so we're not
talking about adverse side effects let's
talk about the adverse effects the main
effects it is intended to interfere with
the normal natural development of the
child the whole point is to force their
bodies to artificially remain in a
prepubescent State that's what the drugs
are being used for if anything the Daily
wire vastly understated the dangers
involved in this practice because that
wasn't the subject of the article I
thought there was anything dishonest
there but the subject of the article was
about the side effects but if anything
that that you know that leaves a side
that that paints a in some ways rosier
picture then what is actually the case
because the primary effect the desired
stated primary effect of these drugs is
itself horrible so we don't even need to
get into any of the rest of it now NBC
quotes a guy named dr. Jack turbine who
discussed the hazards of quote allowing
puberty to progress that's a quote from
the NBC article that's a quote them
quoting doctor dr. Jack turbid them them
uncritically quoting him when he says
that you know there can be problems with
quote allowing puberty to progress
allowing it to progress see puberty is
not a disease it isn't cancer prostate
cancer is cancer
that's why Lupron makes sense in those
cases but doctors like Jack turbine want
to treat a healthy normal stage of
growth as some sort of malignancy now if
NBC was a real news outlet which it
isn't but if it were it would be
debunking the great and I wouldn't be
trying to debunk The Daily wire or me it
would be debunking the great fraud
that's being perpetrated by the medical
industry at the expense of these
innocent children at the very least it
would express some level of skepticism
at the claim that puberty should
literally be treated like cancer if a
child is confused about its gender they
have no skepticism of that they don't
ask any questions so I say it again
these doctors are literally treating
puberty like cancer they are prescribing
the same things for it that they would
for cancer to stop puberty which is
normal and healthy it is part of growing
for a child
no skepticism from not just NBC but but
any of these left-wing outlets no more
much less moral indignation which is
what there really should be these are
these Slayers of the fake news dragon
are more than happy to present radical
far-left crazy gender theory as fact
they just put it out there as fact they
don't either this did nothing but this
whole this is radical far left this is
way into Looney Toon Ville stuff we're
talking about and NBC just puts it out
there says yep this is how it is they
even in their headline of the article
they call puberty blockers trans
healthcare that's how they refer to it
in the in the in the headline they say
trans healthcare because you know
conservatives are attacking trans
health care quote-unquote no indication
that this form of quote health care is
to put it mildly controversial they
don't even bother saying you know
alleged trans health care or or or what
is reported to be by some trans health
care or controversial trans health it'll
put any kind of qualifier in front of
all they just say it's health care and
now a quick word from our friends at
calming comfort you know every night
probably like you I I try to fall asleep
but there are days when anxiety and
stress and everything keeps me awake no
matter what I take no matter what I do
I'm just lying there try to count the
Sheep that doesn't work finally I tried
calming comfort by sharper image the
luxurious weighted blanket that helps
you relax so you can fall asleep and
stay asleep naturally guys I gotta admit
I was a weighted blanket skeptic I think
I could say that I was a skeptic about
it everyone's talking about the weighted
blankets and I thought well how in the
world can adding weight to a blanket
make any difference whatsoever well I
have now been converted hallelujah there
is no need to suffer through another
sleepless night with calming cover
calming comfort is designed way this is
how it works with high-density comfort
filled to provide exactly the right
amount of weight to help your body relax
calm and comfort applies an even amount
of pressure over your body to help the
production of serotonin and melatonin
simulating deep touch pressure
stimulation and that's that's sort of
the science behind it the main thing
though is just that it does help it's
made with supersoft Velveteen material
and designed to promote a sense of
calmness and relaxation for a more
restful night's sleep and you wake up
and you just feel a lot better the
calming comfort weighted blanket comes
with a 90-day anxiety free stress free
best night's sleep of your life
guarantee from sharper image right now
just for our listeners you can go to
calming comfort blanket calm use promo
code Walsh at checkout to receive 15%
off the displayed price again it's
calming comfort blanket comp remote code
Walsh and because you can't put a price
on a great night's sleep go online now
at calming comfort blanket calm and use
promo code Walsh for your special
discount today now
in reality of course no drug could ever
be an effective treatment for gender
dysphoria no matter the age nope oh I
suppose I should say no drug that
physically alters the healthy
development of a child could ever be an
effective treatment for genders for you
now whether there could be some kind of
mental you know some sort of drug
dealing you know that that's a some
psychotropic kind of drug that might
yeah that I would be very skeptical of
too but um this is a mental disorder
though that's the point the gender
dysphoria which is what we're talking
about here this is not a physical
disorder this is something this is
something going on in the mind and I
think and one of the reasons I'd be very
skeptical of using any kind of drug is
that as I said before I think in most of
these cases it really just comes down to
parenting it's very simple in most of
these caveman at all but most the gender
dysphoria Neil's trapped inside a body
that doesn't match that's a direct quote
I'm using a phrase from the National
Health Service in the UK that's how they
describe it trapped inside a body that
doesn't match quote-unquote that
obviously cannot be anything but a
mental disorder obviously it should go
without saying that a person cannot
actually be trapped in the wrong body
that can't actually be happening so if a
person feels like that's the case it's
something going on in the mind obviously
that's the only thing it can be because
our minds are not these entirely
separate entities that are placed inside
our bodies on some sort of cosmic
assembly line and something might go
wrong in the factory you know
manufacturing process and the wrong mind
is put into into the wrong body that
that that can't happen obviously that
can't be the case so this is a very
strange force sort of do
ilysm that you find going on the people
that would affirm this idea that yeah
maybe their mind doesn't match their
body
that is the weirdest kind of dualism
this is this is this is superstitious
they even and and what makes it even
more absurd is that most of the people
who subscribe to this and who would
affirm it and say this is you know
somehow it really can't happen that you
can end up in the wrong body most of
them probably if you ask them given that
this is mostly on the left side of the
spectrum probably most of them don't
even believe in a human soul which is
the only way that you can even begin to
make sense of that certainly if we have
no soul then where it's just our brain
in our body you know we are our body and
nothing more so whatever your body is
that's you that's it that's all there is
to it there's nothing else that's just
you if you feel like you're supposed to
be something else or you are you're just
you're mistaken why you're mistaken well
that's when we get into is there
something going on in the brain is there
something going on with how you were
raised
whatever is it some of those some of
some of both so when you leave the soul
aside there is no way to make sense of
this at all it just it cannot be you are
your body that's it there cannot be any
mismatching but even if you bring the
soul into it it still doesn't make any
sense because even from the perspective
of most people believe in Souls it's
it's not like your soul your body is
some sort of container and your soul is
just placed in sided poured inside it
like a liquid that's not it and even if
it was that way well the only person
that could do the pouring of the soul
would be God and I think we can assume
he's not gonna make a mistake and put
the the wrong soul in the wrong body so
no matter how you look at it whether
you're matter what your metaphysics are
no matter if you're religious or not it
just isn't there's no way to look at
this other than if someone feels that
way they are mistaken they are deluded
they are suffering then either from
terrible parenting or a mental disorder
or both that's it
I can no more have the wrong sex than I
can have the wrong left pinky finger or
the wrong eye color I am Who I am spy
logically speaking I cannot be anything
more than that anything other than that
no matter how I might feel about it
if I have trouble accepting my
biological nature then the correct
treatment must involve and must be
directed towards helping me to accept it
if I have trouble accepting something
that is inevitably and permanently in
immutably true such as my biological
identity then correct and good treatment
would be all about helping me to accept
it it would not ever involve deforming
mutilating poisoning or castrating me or
suppressing my healthy physical
development in any way just to conform
more with my delusional beliefs about
myself it could never involve it because
that would be exact it would be like if
you had an anorexic come in another kind
of body dysmorphia an anorexic someone
who's who's you know think of someone
who's rail-thin
has an eating disorder feels like
they're overweight they're not they
think they are they're sudden some it's
a it's a mental health problem and they
are stats what they are suffering it is
very real suffering it is potentially
fatal so what do we do with someone like
that we help them to realize who they
really are
which is not an overweight person we
help them to see that that what they
perceive about themselves is incorrect
but honestly and I don't say this as a
joke at all this is not a joke to me it
seems when you when you have a child
who's eight years old or nine years old
ten years old doesn't matter how old the
person is when it's a child just makes
it all the worse but you got a child a
boys as he feels like he's a girl
putting it on putting him on puberty
blockers so that he can look more like
what he feels like even though how he
feels is wrong not wrong morally like
there's something morally wrong but
wrong it's just wrong factually doing
that it would be like a anorexic person
coming and saying they feel overweight
and so what you prescribe for them
is a funhouse mirror like at a carnival
you know those mirrors that you look at
it makes you look like you're 200 pounds
heavier than you are that's what it's
like because what you're doing is you're
saying this person has delusional
feelings whether it's awesome so I'm
going to help them see themselves more
in that deluded light I mean it is like
sending an anorexic home with a funhouse
mirror and diet pills laxatives saying
well this is how you feel about yourself
so it must be true here's diet pills
here's laxatives here's a mirror so that
you can better see your true self but of
course we would never do that because
that would be cruel and insane psychotic
to do that to somebody I mean it's it
you might you're basically murdering
them is what you're doing we would never
do that with someone like that but with
a child who has a very basic confusion
and a confusion that probably nine times
out of ten can be easily corrected what
we do instead is we is we start to mess
with their bodies and mutilate and
deform them it is unbelievably evil and
NBC News has nothing but thumbs-up and
approval for it
and now a word from Noom well you know I
must admit that I am I myself I'm not
good at breaking bad habits I'm not good
at forming good habits is anyone I don't
know I I certainly I'm certainly not and
the thing is if you want to get healthy
if you want to get in shape if you want
to make those changes in your life it's
got to start with breaking the bad
habits and forming good ones it has to
start on that level and that's where
Noom comes in that's what Numa is all
about Noom is a habit changing solution
that helps users to learn to develop a
new relationship with food through
personalized courses based in psychology
Noom teaches you why you do the things
you do and then it arms you with the
tools to break the bad habits and form
better ones they say that it's it's
based on cognitive behavioral it's the
cognitive behavioral approach those
words are too
for me it just it works alright it's as
simple as that that's that's all you
need to know Noom is not a diet it is a
healthy and easy to stick to way of life
no food is good or bad or off limits in
and of itself noon teaches moderation
and it can be used in conjunction with
many pre-existing popular diets if
that's what you want to do you don't
have to change it all in one day
small steps make a big big difference
sign up for your trial today at noon n o
m.com slash Walsh what do you have to
lose visit new mom slash Walsh to start
your trial today that's Noom comm slash
Walsh the last weight loss program
you're ever gonna need alright let's
let's go to this will lighten the mood a
little bit
so to speak in a way we're doing absent
because more footage of Justin Trudeau
in blackface has surfaced and I'm not
gonna spend a lot of time with this but
I just wanted to I mean I have to play
it just so you can see if you didn't see
this going around online here's here's
the the videos no sound or anything and
what you see that's not I don't know
exactly when this is from I think it
might have been from last week and that
no I don't think it was last week it's
probably much further back than that but
he's who knows because this guy just
this guy loves blackface at this point I
think we have more footage of Trudeau in
blackface than in not in blackface has
he ever not been in black do we have we
ever actually seen Justin Trudeau
without the blackface I'm now I'm
starting to lose count because it just
say is everyday it's another thing but
you see it's not just blackface he's got
black knees too he's he's he's painted a
whole body what he went all out
he's got the wig he got he's got
everything this is I mean what you see
there is is I I said last week or two
weeks ago when this stuff first started
coming out that it's of course it's
totally inappropriate Justin Trudeau
deserves to be criticized for it he
should be held to his own standards he
would be the first one to call someone
else racist for this but I said at the
time two couple weeks ago that
okay that thing where he was would have
originally was at a talent show or
something was that what it was or no
he's dressed as Aladdin at a costume
party right that was the first one we
saw and I said yea inappropriate of Lee
speaking I don't know that if I would
call it racist because I don't think we
could say he had racist intent though
that's what he would say about someone
else that we should hold him to his own
standard again but now with more of this
stuff coming out it's hard not to see it
as just straight-up racist it's hot you
look at that costume how do you look at
that as anything other than straight-up
racist and how did he not know so to
believe it's not racist we would have to
believe that he didn't know there was
totally innocent he had no idea that
there was anything wrong with this but
even if that footage is back from the
90s or something
I remember the 90s okay I was a kid in
the 90s and I knew in the 90s that you
don't dress up in blackface I knew that
as a kid in the 90s a child so how did
he not know that and if he knew and he
did it anyway then it seems like we may
have real racist intent here either way
but hold on a second there's actually
more to this this clip because this is
so this is from some boating trip or
something that Trudeau went on and
there's a little bit more to to it watch
this okay you've got no sound again but
you've got a guy who appears to be on
drugs acting like an ostrich I guess or
something and then the other guy with
the whitest dance moves of all time so
what what is it happening here was
Trudeau trying to balance out I mean
what what is it what's going on you've
got a couple of the whitest things
you've ever seen that dancing now I'm no
dancer myself but that is if that's the
whitest dancing I've ever that's that's
it that's if any of you look up white
dancing in the dictionary it's that that
is exactly that to a tee so was Trudeau
trying to balance out the whitest thing
ever to happen a corny white dude
dancing in a clown wig on it on a
rafting trip was he trying to balance
that out was he concerned that the sheer
volume of whiteness might rip open a
hole in the space-time continuum and so
we needed so I don't know hey you know
who knows I'm just theorizing but I
think we need to talk to Trudeau about
this we need answers
who is the ostrich man who's the dancing
man
what is he dancing - I'm guessing
smashmouth we need to find out we need
to know Trudeau must answer for this all
right by the way one other thing before
we get before we get back to a very
serious topic there's a there's a
headline from from page six I wanted to
show you also the headline you'll take a
look at it here it says Kate Middleton
re wears blue Alexander McQueen coat for
fourth time I just want to show you that
because there's just more evidence that
society is deteriorating around us
fourth time fourth time disgusting
personally I wear my coats once I throw
them out after that like a civilized
person I walk in my door I toss my coat
at the feet of my Butler William I say
William dispose of that immediately it
displeases me I'm shocked to learn that
Kate Middleton lacks my class and
sophistication I am I am completely
floored by that shameful all right um
okay so last thing before we get the
emails and I I've been I've been
stalling as maybe you can tell because I
really don't want to talk about this
because it's so horrifying in
stomach-churning and I almost feel bad
bring bringing this to you as the viewer
or listener but I think I have to
because it's it's important and it's
necessary that we face it the New York
Times has done some real journalism
every once in a while they do some real
journalism and and here's an example of
it this is real journalism and it's
about the proliferation of child
pornography on the Internet the problem
well you knew the problem was bad or I
think we all we all knew that but it's
it's worse than you thought it's
certainly worse than I thought
much worse I'm not going to read the
whole lengthy report that they just
published I think it was yesterday they
published it I recommend you go and look
up the article titled the Internet is
overrun with images of child sexual
abuse what went wrong now I warn you it
is very very very disturbing infuriating
sickening it does include some
descriptions of some of the things that
these that you know police have
uncovered in there so far mostly futile
attempts to fight this problem it is
like I said much worse in volume then I
think we realized consider this all
right according to The Times report in
1998 there were 3,000 images of child
sexual abuse online which is a lot we
can all agree in 2008 there was 100,000
today 10 years after that and 20 years
about 20 years after the there was after
1998 when there were 3,000 images there
are 45 million images and videos of
child sex abuse online 45 million from a
hundred thousand ten years ago 45
million I mean 10 years from now what
what's it gonna be there is an
exponential growth rate that has been
happening ever since the ever since the
internet was a thing right and ever
since the internet was basically a
household item in the late 90s there's
been this exponential growth infestation
maybe it's a better word of child
pornography and it's not slowing down
it's speeding up in fact and much of it
is the worst and most evil and depraved
kind of stuff you could possibly imagine
very young kids infants in some cases
being tortured and raped and this stuff
is being shared through encrypted
messages hidden on dark web forums where
thousands and thousands of people go to
share and view it like I said go to the
New York Times to read the ages I think
it's important for us all to know what's
out there
and this is the kind of thing that as a
society we should be focusing on this is
a problem that and it should be
something that we can all agree on it's
one of the only things that we should
all be able to agree this is a huge
problem something has to be done and
drastic steps have to be taken I would
think that all those three points we
could all agree the article goes into
detail about the trouble that law
enforcement has in controlling this
because these child raping scumbags are
experts in the technology that they need
to hide their tracks now think about how
monstrous these people are that they
have you know they have become experts
in this technology they have learned it
in some cases better than the FBI knows
it just so that they can engage in this
kind of activity
so the question obviously is and this is
what the article deals with the question
is what do you do about it how do you
get rid of this stuff
I think one thing is you have to put a
lot more legal pressure on Facebook
Google all these companies to seek this
stuff out not just to not just to try to
censor it once it's reported to them but
to seek it out to find it on their own
platforms in their own networks and to
not just shut it down but to find who
where it's coming from
so there needs to be more of an effort
on that end but here's something else I
think we should do that the article does
not talk about I think we need an
isn't gonna solve the problem I know
that but I think it could at least make
a dent in it and it is the right thing
to do
we need the death penalty for child
pornographers pornographers and it needs
to be public there are people raping and
torturing toddlers and sharing it online
and these people are they're not people
they are beasts they are animals they
have forfeited their claim to humanity
they have forfeited their right to live
it's just it's gone they don't have it
they have no right to be alive as far as
I could see it and I think society has
to act act with swift and righteous and
uncompromising vengeance yes vengeance
against these people because you know
it's not just about deterring although
it is partly that and like I said this
isn't gonna solve the problem but I do
think it and it will have some deterring
effect it has to do when these child
raping scumbags start to see that their
friends and their and their little
pornography networks not so little
unfortunately networks online are being
caught and hung executed for it I would
think that would have to have some
effect on you psychologically but even
if it had no deterring effect it's not
just about that it's not just about
tutoring it's not just about segregating
dangerous people from society although
it's partly about that too
it's not just about you know saving
money so they don't have to provide for
these people in prison for the next 40
years of their worthless pathetic lives
although it's partly about that it is
also along with those things it is also
just it is vengeance right righteous
vengeance where we are saying you have
done the worst thing a person can do and
you have victimized children in horrific
ways that will be with them forever and
so now you are going to face the Khan
sequences on behalf of of these victims
and on back
behalf of society in general this is
vengeance and so you're gonna die yeah
we're not we're not gonna put you in
jail for 20 years and let you get out
and do it again we're not gonna no
nothing like that
you have your trial convicted shortly
thereafter we take out we hang you and
we throw you in an unmarked grave
because that's all that's all you are
you don't deserve to be remembered as a
person
III really believe that this is the this
is the the oh the only correct approach
this is the moral and right approach to
these kinds of crimes and not just not
just this as you know as I've talked
about on the show my thinking on issues
like the death penalty has evolved
considerably and now I am yeah I was I
wrestled with it for a long time but the
more and more I've thought about it and
especially in relation to crimes like
this I just cannot see any other
appropriate way to deal with them I read
a story I just read a report about a
child pornographer in Kentucky who is
found guilty of dozens of counts of
child pornography and and you know by
the way that somebody's found guilty of
whatever fifteen counts of child
pornography you know the actual number
is a thousand times that okay because
people don't have you know people don't
just look at child pornography a couple
of times it they this is just what they
do is we found this they're obsessed
with it
so anyway 15 confirmed counts of child
pornography and he's what the article
says he's facing 30 years in prison
which means that that means that's the
top that's the most he might get and he
probably won't even get that and even if
he does get that he'll probably be out
before that to probably get paroled
before that that's just not nearly
enough that is that is
doesn't come anywhere close to society
expressing its absolute outrage and
disgust and anger all all of which are
righteous ad men like this okay
let's and I know that there's there you
know if we if they if in this this law
will never happen what I'm what I'm
proposing will never happen I realize
that and and even if someone did try to
move in that direction we're gonna run
into the problem the Supreme Court has
said that it's unconstitutional to
execute child rapist which is crazy I
think it's one of their worst decisions
they've ever patent they passed some bad
ones so you had to have a Supreme Court
issue as well but although I think that
now I believe that what the Supreme
Court has dealt with in the past our
issues of can you can you execute Java
Lester's rapist and so on when you deal
specifically with well what about those
people who do this and then also are
part of a network of child pornographers
online so I think maybe there might be a
loophole you could get through there a
loophole into which you can stuff these
people's necks and close it around them
okay let's go to emails Matt wall show
at gmail.com Matt wall show at gmail.com
we're gonna wrap evolution up we're
gonna settle the whole evolution debate
there it's gonna be settled after this
we've talked about a couple times now in
the email section so I'll do a few more
emails and then and then that'll be it
because after that I'm sure we all have
agreed now we've all come to the
conclusion the same conclusion right
this is from Bill says dear madam
writing a response to your discussion of
evolution last week I think your
dismissal of the irreducible complexity
objection to Darwin's natural selection
working on random variation was too
facile I recommend most highly the works
of the godfather of irreducible
complexity Lehigh University biochemist
Michael Bay he Darwin's black box etc
but quickly the point is a genuine case
of irreducible complexity if it exists
at all doesn't have a gradual Darwinian
step by tiny step formation storyline
Bay he uses the example of a mousetrap
there are several parts all of which
need to be present
for the trap to function at all if for
example you start with the wooden
platform and then add a spring you don't
go from catching no mice to catching
some mice you still catch no mice this
is true from any combination of its
parts except the final completed
combination of its parts in your
dismissal of irreducible complexity you
offer the emergence of the vertebrate
eye as an example I would argue I would
agree that half an eye is better than
1/4 of an eye which is better than a
light-sensitive spot but that scenario
if it's a legitimate storyline for the
emergence of the eye has intermediate
with increasing functional capacity to
recommend themselves to the natural
selection subcommittee deciding its fate
a genuine case of irreducible complexity
of which I think the bacterial flagellum
is an example has no hypothetical
intermediate stage which has any
function to recommend its stay of
execution knockout experiments
demonstrate that when individual
component parts of its structure are
removed the whole structure is not just
less efficient at its job it doesn't do
its job at all this is the rub for
Darwinian explanation and if this were
just an isolated example in a sea of
easily explicit explicable cases it
could probably be be chalked up to
biochemical pathway ignorance but as I
understand the demographics of cells
there is a very large and continually
growing contingent of irreducibly
complex entities and one more thing
baekjae I think is also a Roman Catholic
with no axe to grind when it comes to
evolution he thinks there's good
evidence to support common descent but
still only sees evidence for a limited
scope for the efficacy of natural
selection working on random variation
see his book the edge of evolution
yeah the full gel 'm is a tough case
like a lot of emails about that I admit
it's a tough case it's a good point I
also admit that I don't know nearly
enough about cellular biology to speak
very extensively on the subject if I
tried to go into detail I probably would
embarrass myself from what I understand
well first of all speaking of the Fuji
speaking of the flagellum in general is
from what I understand a little bit
confusing
because there are many different they're
different flagella and they vary in what
they do and and what they look like so
there's more variation already then
maybe your
let's on and from what I understand
there are there are plenty of theories
and ideas as to how these flagella may
have been formed this I don't think this
is an argument that makes a biologist
stop and go WOW well it's impossible
then for evolution to be true but but I
think that's what you would need to
prove right you would need to prove you
were baekjae or whoever else not just
that it's unlikely or hard to understand
or even that we don't know how it
happened because you can't do
essentially a creationism of the gapps
thing where you point out the gaps and
you say current scientific understanding
cannot explain this and so therefore I'm
correct so you can't do that you would
need to show that it is impossible that
there is no possible way that evolution
could work through natural selection on
something like the flagellum and and I
don't think that that has been shown or
or proved so for me it comes down to
that but when as we talked about last
week a theory is all about explaining
natural phenomenon well almost no theory
that I can think of off the top my head
can explain everything there are still
going to be gaps in our understanding
now the point is that those gaps have
been closing steadily as we learn more
about the natural world and how things
work but the presence of gaps doesn't in
and of itself prove whatever competing
theory true especially if that competing
theory has a number of gaps itself
and that's what does one of the reasons
why I know you didn't bring this up but
this is one of the reasons why and some
people took me to task because I sort of
waved off the fossil issue as if it's as
if it's irrelevant now it's not
irrelevant think it's I said it's
irrelevant I said it's not nearly as
relevant as when you get into genetics
and you get into the to that level of
things but the fossil the problem with
bringing fossils up is as I said vast
vast vast majority of life forms never
do fossilized that's just the reality
the vast majority of those that do are
not going to be found because we're not
excavating the entire earth so
inevitably by the nature of the thing
there are going to be fossils you don't
find there gonna be you're gonna find
gaps in the fossil records of course you
are
we're not gonna know you'd be
unreasonable to demand that every single
fossil be found in that a you could
showed of course it so the problem is
when people who deny evolution come
along and they point to those fossil
gaps and they say that see there you go
we've been proven correct
they haven't been proven correct by the
absence of this this or that thing I
think what you have to do and I think
you you mentioned this bill and I agree
with you that you have to look at the
totality if they look at the the the
cumulative case that both theories can
make not based on the absence of
evidence of the other theory but based
on their own evidence what actual real
evidence can you bring forward to
actively prove your own theory and I
think when you look at added on that
level I still think the evolutionary
theory has just way more evidence to
recommend itself from my perspective
this is from Steve says Matt Darwinism
evolution was intended to show that
there is no design or purpose in nature
but that it is undirected and random it
is a materialistic theory that promotes
the belief that there is nothing beyond
matter and energy there is no
supernatural there is no god there's no
designer or designer design or designer
it is incompatible with Christianity or
any religion that believes in
supernatural forces aside from the fact
that there are questions that I have not
had answered by evolutionists we
came first plant life or animal life how
do creatures evolve digestive systems to
meet a different environment over
thousands or millions of years creatures
that starve to death can't reproduce to
have those changes evolved how did
sexual reproduction of all and as a land
creature evolve into a sea creature
without dying and vice versa how would
the body of a creature know how to
develop the systems necessary to live in
a completely new environment over
thousands or millions of years if you
say that anything is possible with
enough time and chance as evolution
requires isn't that just a isn't that
just magic and not science
Darwin's theory is not fact and when
honestly examined with science it falls
apart the Darwinist faithful do not want
to let go of it because it allows them
to have a godless purely materialistic
explanation of the world but they desire
I suggest Jonathan wells icons of
evolution to illustrate or Jonathan
wells icons of evolution to illustrate
how Darwinist Darwinists used misleading
and false information to promote their
disproven theory okay Steve I'm not
going to dissect every every sentence of
this email I think there a number a
number of problems here first of all
it's a claim that evolution has been
disproven I you know I mean you you can
go ahead and make the argument that you
doesn't you're not convinced by it
because for this or that reason and go
ahead and make that argument I'm not
saying that that's a stupid argument to
make but to say that it's been disproven
is that's just incorrect I don't you
know I doubt among people who understand
the science who really understand it and
who don't accept evolution I don't think
any of them would say that evolution has
been quote disproven because disproven
to disprove that is a you're setting the
bar for the burden of proof for you is
extremely high and you're gonna have to
do a lot better than what you just did
to disprove it
as far as people just want to believe in
Darwinism because it allows them have a
godless universe that's just well how do
you explain me then I mean right I meant
like that I can I can disprove that
right now just with myself so I can
prove that that isn't certainly at least
not the only possible reason why
somebody might believe in evolution
somebody might believe in it
quote-unquote because they really just
think that's where the evidence points
and that's where I fall I don't have any
axe to grind with religion obviously and
there are plenty of other Christians and
members of other religions now you might
say or you can't possibly be religious
and believe in evolution well yeah but a
lot of people are you can argue that
they shouldn't be or that they don't
understand or whatever but to try to get
into motivation and to say well the only
reason why somebody would believe in
this is because they're trying to
disprove God that obviously is not true
I can say from experience that is not
true what else here I didn't want to
overlook anything and then okay the
various questions you asked about how do
you get from plant life to animal life
and so on the beings evolving out of the
water and then onto land and in some
cases going back into the water like as
would be the case with say for instance
whales well you mention it in your other
paragraph that really for a lot of that
stuff it does come down to time that
when you think of things on a on the
scale that we tend to think of things
which for us you know quick would be an
hour and a long time would be a day or a
year or even a lifetime that's how we
think of things so on that scale all the
questions you just asked are
unanswerable it is it's impossible to
understand
evolutionary theory on the scale that we
think with expect when you think of
things on the timescale and you consider
that Earth has been around for four
billion years and life at its most
rudimentary level has probably existed
for three billion years which means
you've got a billion years of no life
before I even get to life then
another three billion years basically to
get from that most rudimentary level to
human beings when you consider that time
scale I think it it handles most of your
questions and that's not it's not a
cop-out it's just you the time is very
important so you have to keep going back
to it that's a VI and I do believe that
I'm not saying this is a case for
everybody but many people who doubt
evolution I think for a lot of them part
of the reason they doubt it is because
they they haven't totally considered the
timescale that we're talking about and
what it really means or if they're young
earth creationists they because of their
theology which i think is mistaken they
can't consider it on that side so
they're thinking of everything in terms
of 6,000 years now that's true if the
whole universe is 6,000 years old then
yeah there's no time for any of this
stuff to have happen and so evolution
couldn't be the case but I think the
universe is in fact 14 billion years and
the earth is about four to five billion
years old all right from Andrew says hi
Matt my reason for rejecting evolution
is maybe too simple but I'll be honest I
reject it because it is clear to me that
human life is just too incredible to
beautiful Deb in the product a product
of blind chance even animal life
Eagles bears dogs etc is all way too
majestic and wonderful I know this isn't
a scientific answer but that's how I
feel well there's nothing first of all
don't apologize for making an argument
that isn't isn't scientific exactly
there's nothing wrong with making an
argument like that I get what you're
saying I suspect that probably most
people on your side of the issue would
agree that this is one of their main
reasons for rejecting evolution it's a
very visceral reason where you look and
you see how incredible human life is how
beautiful so much of life is and you
think well this there's no way that that
evolution can explain them I would make
two points though number one nobody is
talking about blind chance natural
selection as a mechanism for
facilitating evolution is not chance
it's sort of the opposite of chance
really as far as blind well I guess as I
suppose an atheist wouldn't have to say
that it's blind in a sense yeah I don't
think it's blind though
so I would say that it's neither blind
nor chance and anyone who accepts
evolution would agree at a minimum that
it's not chance yes the genetic
mutations are random but the process of
natural selection is not random is not a
roll of the dice
it couldn't be if it was then yeah
there's no way you could have anything
that we see around us explained by
evolution but that's not what the theory
says so I would say it's not blind or
chance second to the this sort of
esthetic argument of how beautiful life
is I agree human life is beautiful bears
and eagles are majestic totally agree
with that the problem though is that
this argument cuts both ways and I think
it cuts more against you than for you
because the world is also host to some
very I would say not beautiful
life-forms or at least some some
life-forms that would be very difficult
some life-forms that only their mothers
could love I put it that way
think of the wasp that lays its eggs
inside a caterpillars body and then its
babies eat the caterpillar from the
inside and this is how the wasp lives
this is how the wasp reproduces and
survives it does is what it does it's
not just that some of these wasps do
this this is this is the behavior of the
entire species think of tapeworms that
can only survive inside the intestines
of larger organisms think of spiders
that eat their mates and eat their own
babies think of parasitic fungi that
take over the brains of ants and turn
them into zombies there are many many
many examples of this kind of thing life
that it would be very hard to call
majestic or beautiful head lice
mosquitoes or on one now on evolution
the proliferation of parasitic types of
species is very easy to explain in fact
it's what you would expect Eve even even
if you didn't know that any of these
life-forms existed
but you knew about the theory of
evolution you would predict that
probably these kinds of creatures are
out there because it makes sense on a
Darwinian model right but on the view
that God individually and specifically
created each species apart from any
natural process of evolution well then
you have to explain why God would make
the wasp that lays its eggs inside a
caterpillars body or the tapeworm that
must live inside the bellies of third
world people or the mosquito that sucks
blood and spreads disease on a view that
God allows evolution to operate to work
according to its own laws and processes
on that view then this problem becomes a
little bit less of a problem but on your
view I think I think you've got some
splainin to do I think it becomes much
more so it's sort of similar we talked
last week about Calvinism and I said how
the problem of suffering is is a
difficult challenge for any theists to
meet it's one of those problems that we
wrestle with and you think about and
everything but on a non Calvinistic view
it it's it's not a devastating problem
it's not like it you know it has to make
you abandon your belief in God there are
ways of dealing with it especially
because you have something like free
will and that can explain not all of the
suffering in the world but a lot of it
where God allows people to make choices
but I said on the Calvinistic view it
seems like the problem of suffering is
totally devastating and in
insurmountable because then you really
are specifically blaming God for all of
the suffering where God engineers
everything there really is no free will
and everything is directly done
conducted by God as this sort of puppet
master this cosmic puppet master figure
so I think on on Calvinism the problem
with suffering is very difficult
it's basically insurmountable I would
say that on
anti-evolution view the issues raised by
some of these rather horrific life forms
that are parasitic and that can only
survive by victimizing other forms of
life I think on the non evolutionary
view it raises some pretty tough
theological question it's not it's not
insurmountable like Calvinism is not
it's so it's not the exact same
relationship like it is between the
problems suffering in Calvinism I think
there are ways you know I'm sure the
ways you could probably explain it I'm
just trying to point out that the issue
you bring up it does cut both ways as I
said and I do think it cuts more against
you than for you whereas for me as
someone who thinks that evolution is
true I would say again that it's it's a
similar sort of idea to free will not
that it is free will but God gives us
free will that's how the world works we
are allowed to make choices and that
includes bad choices
same thing with evolution that's how the
world works as decided by God and so
it's going to have certain results not
all of them are going to be especially
pleasant alright we will leave it there
thanks everybody for watching and
listening I will have should have one
more show tomorrow before I'm off for a
few days we my wife is scheduled we have
it now scheduled two for the baby to
make her appearance so one more show
tomorrow and hope you guys have a great
night Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by
Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena Matt
Walsh show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
we'll see you there
[Music]